this video was brought to you by
playstation
who is miles morales well first up let's
start with a big caveat
we are talking strictly about the miles
of earth 1048
better known as the marvel's spider-man
universe and not his other incarnations
on the printed page
and the big screen it's just gonna be
easier that way
in marvel's spider-man miles morales we
joined the titular hero one year after
the conclusion of marvel's spider-man
and its dlc
marvels spider-man the city that never
sleeps and clearly
those 12 months have made quite the
difference
to understand how and why miles has
ended up in this
sleek figure-hugging and instantly
iconic suit
it's best to go back to the start miles
morales is an
incredibly intelligent teenager with a
knack for technology
but otherwise pretty normal however his
life becomes
inextricably linked with his favorite
superhero spider-man
when his father police officer jefferson
davis saves his idol after a run-in with
the criminal organization
the demons tragically jefferson is
killed at a ceremony intended to
commemorate his bravery
while characteristically attempting to
protect others from a terrorist attack
by the demon's leader
mr negative a devastated miles becomes
withdrawn
and reckless until encounters with both
peter parker and spider-man
gives his life purpose and direction
again
following in his father's footsteps
miles repeatedly demonstrates a
propensity for selfless acts of bravery
including sneaking around the one-man
wrecking crew rhino while hunting down
antibiotics and
saving spidey from a fiery demise he
also demonstrates the same compassion
and generous spirit as peter and ends up
volunteering at feast
the homeless shelter managed by may
parker it's there that his connection to
peter grows even deeper as
for reasons too complicated to go into
here he is bitten by an experimental
spider from norman osborne's secret lab
months later miles starts to show signs
of his own burgeoning superpowers and
tells the one person he can trust with
his secret
who just so happens to be the only
person who can empathize with his
condition
as revealed in marvel's spider-man the
city that never sleeps dlc
peter takes a slightly every eager miles
under his wing
even going so far as to lend him a mask
while he shows him the ropes
well the webs a year on and miles is now
a full-fledged spider-man complete with
his own distinctive suit and unique
range of powers it also seems that his
circle of trust has extended beyond
peter
evidenced by his exchange with best
friend genki lee
are you still wearing your suit yeah you
know just in case
we also see that his mother rio morales
has left behind her life as a teacher to
enter into politics and is running for
city council
which in true spider-man fashion looks
to put her in
immediate danger and while i said i
wouldn't be discussing the comics if you
want to know where peter parker got the
inspiration for miles
striking new suit it's worth reading
2018's spider-geddon event series
so to return to my original question who
is
miles morales simple he's spider-man
[Music]
playstation